there's quite a bit of anti-muslim
sentiment in the United States
especially after 9 11. I've spoken to
people about that
there's also
anti-jewish anti-Semitism sentiment in
the United States but also throughout
human history
what do you make about
this kind of
um fact of human nature that people seem
to hate Jews throughout history
especially in the 20th century
especially with Nazi Germany
what are your in general thoughts about
the hatred of the Jewish people I mean I
think it's obviously wrong I don't know
it's it's this it's this idea that even
have to clarify what I think about
anti-Semitism that doesn't say right
well with me I think it's completely
unfortunate and wrong that
um Jewish people have been prosecuted
across history so one of the criticisms
I think I read the ADL making this
criticism of you is uh maybe you've
tweeted a comparison between uh Israel
and Hitler
and thereby diminishing the evil that is
Hitler
uh what would you say to that let me say
Sarah talks about this a lot
um the exceptionalization of Hitler
um Hitler is a deplorable
I don't know condemnable you know raw
and racist horrible human being that
belongs in the depths of Hell obviously
that's
that goes without without saying but
I am allowed
um analogy
and I'm allowed to say whatever I want
um now I don't necessarily think that
that such an analogy is a good strategy
to have
um but at the time the context came in
um
2021 when
Israeli soldiers and policemen and
settlers were literally burning down our
neighborhood
um Again verifiable by Google
um
and I tweeted it and I also I remember I
tweeted something I hope every single
one of them dies and to this day like
this some kind of uh you know gotsa for
me as if I sort of tweeted like oh
here's the apple pie for every single
soldier that's throwing tear gas in my
house
you know there is
there is such an exceptionalism when it
comes to Palestinians we're not allowed
analogy we're not allowed expression
we're not allowed armed resistance we're
not allowed peaceful resistance we're
not allowed to boycott because that's
anti-semitic we're not allowed to do
anything
um so what are we allowed if I if I
can't boycott and that's against
American law and auto boycott and if I
can't pick up a rifle because that's
against the law and if I can't even
tweet
my frustration out what am I allowed to
do
you know maybe Netanyahu can send me a
manual he's happy with you know
so you've spoken about the taking of
homes
the idea of uh killing civilians killing
children
uh what about the violence going the
other direction Israelis being killed
um in part by terrorist action
well it depends on depends on how you
Define terrorism right across history
one man's Freedom Fighter is another
man's terrorist
um
I don't necessarily subscribe to the
definition of terrorism if uh if a
foreign army is in my neighborhood which
it's not supposed to be and and they're
shooting life ammunition at my house
I'm allowed to do what I'm allowed to do
and again this is another yet another
case of Palestinian exceptionalism
because when it comes to Ukraine
people have no problem
seeing ukrainians defending their homes
seeing ukrainians uh dying further and
seeing ukrainians making makeshift
molotovs on Sky News you know Sky News
was running a mouth of making cocktails
the New York Times read an article
interviewing a Ukrainian psychologist
who said that hatred I'm paraphrasing
but he said hatred for all
um
Russians is actually a healthy Outlet
the New York posts ran a headline
um Champion championing uh quote unquote
heroic Ukrainian suicide bomber
these things we would not even dream of
uh
as as Palestinians
we are we are told to turn the other
cheek time and time again we're told
that we we should continue living these
in inside these enclaves
um without access to clean water without
access to to the right to movement
without access to building permits
without our natural right to expansion
without you know without a guarantee
that if we leave our house we're not
going to be sought and we're supposed to
not do anything about it that is absurd
any any person watching this understands
this completely people understand you
know people understand that if somebody
is attacking your home you'll fight back
if somebody is attacking your family you
fight back that is that is not but again
who gets to call who a terrorist who
gets to Define terrorism this is all
about who has power
who gets to write these laws who gets to
write these definitions
you know why is it um
why is it that American actions and Iraq
is not called terrorism by American
politicians wise you know violence is
like this
new dating mutating concept you know and
it takes on many shapes and forms and if
it's in in a uniform
it's if it speaks in English if it has
blonde hair it's somehow acceptable it's
okay we make
movies about it
you know we sell out
tickets
about it we make games about it but if
it's without a uniform it's if it has a
thick accent if it has a beard you know
that's that's condemnable that's wrong
that's terrorism you know do you think
violence is an effective method of
protest and resistance in general in
general I think it has been but I think
you know I believe in fighting on Old
fronts I don't think violence alone is
gonna bring about change
I think uh
there's so much to do uh in culture and
shifting public opinion there's so much
to do in media and fighting back against
media eraser and census and censorship
there's so much to do diplomatically and
politically
um
um and I I think I would be naive if
I don't take the power imbalance into
consideration
um one side has makeshift weapons and
the other side is one of the most
sophisticated armies in the world
so I don't know I don't know how
effective violence could be in this case
but if you look at the flip side do you
see the power of non-violent resistance
so Martin Luther King Gandhi the power
of attorney the other cheek he spoke
negatively about turning the other cheek
so I sense that uh doing so has not been
effective for the Palestinian people
we've turned the other cheek uh
generation after generation there is
this Zionist Trope that that is used
against us they say Palestinian
rejectionism they say that we reject
everything but if you look at the
history like our leadership the
Palestinian Authority has given up ins
after ends has compromised on acre after
acre has signed deal after deal after
deal after deal and still there is no
peace
so turning the other cheek is not
you know the most effective method in my
book